Try my day.
Joe Rogan podcast by night all day.
Uh,
she was in there.
I never worked with shoes in there.
Great,
great person.
Freak freak.
It's crazy how this fucking
sport just chews people up.
You think you're on top and
then it's gone and it's over.
But the casual fan doesn't kill.
That's why that paper you a cell
because the casual fan goes,
oh,
that's the girl who worked Ronda Rousey.
That's the argument from a Gregor
versus Floyd Bates fucking happening.
That's happening,
but it's going to happen.
See,
so McGregor,
it held a press conference last night,
sold out arena.
5,000 tickets sold out the on the mic.
He goes,
fuck the UFC.
Fuck everything.
He said,
fuck boxing you.
And he goes to the next fight,
the next fight.
Me Verse Floyd.
He was fully get it fucking done.
And then he goes,
I'm going to do it with
or without the UFC.
And they told Dana that.
He goes,
good luck with that.
Good luck getting that done with that.
He believes it with the Ali Act.
He can actually do it because
it's a different sport.
He has the money to hire
the lawyers to try it.
Well it's,
it is an interesting argument
because it's not MMA boxing.
So if it's boxing it's not,
he doesn't have a contrast.
She should just promote it anyways
and work together with Floyd and say,
well done.
It's not just with Floyd,
it's with McGregor promotions
now that he's got his own thing.
That's the key to promote
because they don't want it.
They don't want to have a third middleman
in Dana white cause you have Conor
McGregor promotions,
Floyd Mayweather it,
and then the UFC,
they don't want to give the,
you is going to become what boxing is.
It's going to become that
because it's star driven.
Like all things like music,
hate,
like comedy,
like everything.
It's going to stay star driven.
And when it's star driven like that,
guys like Connor who are legitimate stars,
they have the leverage and they're
going to manipulate that leverage.
They're gonna utilize that leverage
and we're going to see what happened.
Especially right now I just started,
we've ever had,
it's a reality star driven,
but it is a reality.
Why is it?
Why do you hate that?
Because it's always been
like that in boxing.
Well,
right.
I mean that's how they make the
hundred million dollar paydays.
He's a purist and real quick.
Yeah,
me too.
But I would love to see Conor was Floyd.
Rob,
rob and I were talking about fights.
This dude said he's never seen a fight.
He doesn't lie.
Every single fight.
I've hated a lot of fun.
You see Kimbo and Donna.
Okay.
That you got right to it.
Quick.
Right to the point that maybe there maybe.
I did see one seen some shitty fight,
fight,
and he was like,
I liked
each other out.
Gracie's last bite on Bella coil cable.
We were talking about it.
I liked it too.
This is what I liked about
that all bullshit aside.
How Gracie fought a fucking killer.
I mean that guy knocked
out Joe Schilling twice.
He knocked him out and kickboxing
and he knocked him out in MMA.
He's a fucking beast.
He's a very dangerous striker.
He's a very big guy
and he's fucking scary.
He's a blaster and how it,
nothing.
No,
no,
no.
He avoided getting knocked down.
Your boy who's a beast in
new mouth because he scared.
He was worried about getting taken down.
It was scary to get strangled.
And what were you scared of is what
happened in the last minute of the last
round when I did take him
down past his garlic butter,
fucking mounted him and
had him in a bad spot.
Haluk was going to fuck him
up if that fight kept going,
if that was in the first
minute of the first round,
how might fight with fuel to do it
because he hit the guy that you guys think
that was entertaining fight.
Fuck,
fuck,
fuck.
That's great.
And you hated Kim overs.com
that was more hate it.
I didn't hate him,
but it was not a high level fight.
I hated the fact that people were watching
it on TV and both guys were severely
unconditioned.
There were severely out of shape.
Like,
no,
I didn't.
His heartbeat stopped
the hip Revit enough.
That's true.
Is that some of that is him,
but uh,
no.
I,
when I think about it,
honestly,
I hated what the fight was about,
but I love the fight,
the dynamic of what's happening between
these two human beings in combat.
I mean dot.
And Kimbo.
Yeah.
Even that one,
the dynamic between them is different
than every other fight in their case,
Mike,
because chose Mike.
Jamie.
Yeah.
If it was my student
out until I was about,
are you intrigued by the,
by the time Mcgregor,
Floyd Mayweather.
I said as if Conor McGregor could
actually box with Floyd Mayweather.
Mcgregor cannot box with Floyd Mayweather,
but Conor Mcgregor's what?
The only goal that he could have the
workable idea as a backdoor hack.
Something where being unwilling
to make it a boxing match.
He is fighting him with two hands.
But boxing is not the definition
of fighting with two hands.
Find a hack,
find a back door.
What would Tim Ferriss do if Tim,
if you said,
hey,
Tim Ferris,
how,
how do you beat Floyd Mayweather with a
guy who's never pushed him off the stand
yet?
You'd want someone else's
idea and regurgitate.
Yeah.
It's not that easy.
No,
it's not.
But Mcgregor has found the disruption.
Okay.